are you doing today good how are you I'm
doing good
a pleasure to see you again again to the
only oh so before I get started and get
to talk about climax the only reason I
get to talk to you today and be here at
TIFF is because of house of Aurora who
are the sponsors and who have all this
and I just want to give them a huge
shout out and say thank you to them it's
a beautiful place what is it this is a
former bank actually I think this is
built in like the early 1900s it's
gorgeous
yes I wish people watching could
actually see the decor inside so they've
been throwing some parties here at night
you can turn the cameras around at some
point maybe I'll get some b-roll okay
sorry I forget nothing important so what
is it now it was a former bank but what
is it no I don't actually I think it is
upstairs it might be like an office
building I'm not a hundred percent but
they throw a lot of parties here now and
as I said like thank you House of Aurora
thank you house of Aurora
so now let's jump to why I get to talk
to you today yeah so how have you been
describing because it premiered to a lot
of buzz at the festival and can and how
have you been describing the film to
people because what I've seen looks you
know it is a very unique looking movie
filled with it's like pulsating energy
yeah it's quite it's quite rich and
intense I mean you're really jumping on
a roller coaster once you start watching
the film it'll take you on a journey
you'll feel something pretty strongly
and it's almost your opinion would be
yes or no but you will feel something I
for me the experience was so unique and
the the method that we worked with and
the whole process so seeing it after I
had no idea what I was gonna see and I
almost watched it from an audience
perspective and I just I just I was just
baffled by by how he created that art
because it's the story of these dancers
that are perfectly fine and I respite
with a large amount of LSD and seeing
them going internally into this journey
was quite like I saw it twice now and
I'm still baffled by how he created the
arc and when the change is
are being made and I think it's all like
how he deals with rhythm and editing and
and and also the music which has a big
part in the film it's seamless and I
find that fascinating and so I'm I'm
again I think gonna watch it again
tomorrow night and I'm still observing
like how he did things with his
technique but yeah it's definitely a
journey you're jumping on the roller
coaster when you're gonna see it you
were saying to me and I didn't realize
this he was saying off-camera that he
actually was the DP on it that he shot
so talk a little bit about what it's
like working with the director who's
actually also the cinematographer yeah I
mean he has his DP with him but he shot
it like every frame of the film he had
the camera on his shoulder and filmed
every frame we also had the crane for a
day or a day and a half and he
maneuvered that as well I have mad
respect for a director that can grab the
camera and show exactly the movie that
he is seeing from you know inside out
and yeah it was it was it was quite
special like every day we came to set
and we had no idea what we were gonna
shoot because we had only five pages
treatment and we would rehearse for
about four or five hours and like also
we would rehearse eight to ten minute
scenes and then we would have lunch
break and then we would shoot for about
another five hours and we would shoot
about between 14 and 17 takes every day
of eight to ten minute scenes and it
like the rehearsal in the building
process of like the the scene would be
you know depend on the character and
where he wanted to go and where he
wanted to shoot but every day we had no
idea what we're gonna do tomorrow it has
to be really weird seeing it then for
the first time because you really have
no idea what the final movie is gonna
exactly that's why I said when I watched
it for the first time I was complete
audience I was like oh that's the movie
I've done even at the end of shooting
the film the very last day I finally met
my character entirely other than that I
remember first of all Gaspard contacted
me on Instagram which was pretty unusual
and I've I knew his movies of course and
I was a big fan of his work to be honest
and and big respect for his for his
instrument and for what he delivers each
time I just I just did not know the man
and had
idea who I was gonna find and I told my
my agent I said just so you know he
reached out and I happened to be in
Paris so we met up and we sat down all
he said is I just want to explore
dancers and I said what else maybe the
answers that are spiked with a large
amount and us didn't see what happens
and I was just wondering how I was
questioned wondering why the reoccurring
theme like the the sex the drugs or the
violence and he is just the man who is
fascinated with people losing control
and that's in our respect that when an
artist has and I think a lot of time I
don't like to always know why I always
do what they deliver because it doesn't
matter it makes you feel something but I
was really puzzled and I was gonna work
with him so I wanted to understand I
think my character batters were
understanding Gaspard and him saying
that made complete sense and he is just
by far one of the kindest man ever it's
very sweet and one of the most peaceful
set I've ever been on for set where you
don't know what we're gonna do I'm
curious also because when you are gonna
be portraying a character that is
basically tripping balls like how are
you preparing yeah Wow do you not not
like that but are you looking at a lot
of other performances to see what you
admire in a performance or are you
trying to just be authentic to who you
are in the moment no I just first of all
I've never had that happen to me and
I've never done anything that put me in
that state of you know being completely
[ __ ] up and high but I I researched a
lot but real footage I didn't watch
other performances because I didn't want
it to be based off of that and I didn't
necessarily look at LSD I looked at
really hardcore drugs like flaca they're
really scary to observe people on it
it's really it's really traumatizing so
I just went to the you know to that like
looking at real people their own drugs
and and I I try I didn't have much time
because the movie happened pretty
quickly but I wanted to meet real people
there like that and but I didn't go that
far but I looked at a lot of footage I
was completely dead sober during the
movie and you have to in order to create
to be present for your character
of course I didn't do any I didn't do
any drugs to research the character
either sure I would imagine when you are
working as hard as you did you know
working these crazy hours and doing
these you know the rehearsals and this
entire process what is it like on that
first few days after you wrap are you
just like a zombie are you just laying
in bed like how do you recover from like
an experience like this luckily you can
always like out we shot in Paris so I
jumped on the flight not too long after
that and I was swept away towards
various work which helps you know
sometimes it's harder to not have
anything afterwards I am I I did like
was you know sort of like in in shock
was like what just happened and we shot
pretty quickly we only had 15 days so
and we wrapped and then two months later
we were at can already which was pretty
incredible that's an I didn't realize it
was that fast and that's amazing
especially based on the reaction at the
festival because you don't know what
you're gonna get I had no idea and I was
I I loved I loved how it made me feel
and I love how he's still making me feel
I'm still one I'm excited to see it
tomorrow again and I'm just I'm really
fascinated by his technique filming wise
and how he edits and what he does with
the camera like shots that you would see
our magical because that's not how he
shot them and what he does with them
afterwards is pretty incredible and he
knows that he will do that even like
there is the beginnings like you it's
all all so seamless like hey Scott we
did shoot very long takes but
technically he's he's truly a master and
I just respect that a lot and I love how
he trusts spontaneity you know he trusts
where he will go like some like detail
like behind the DJ booth
he asked our department to lay down you
know a bunch of fabric just to have a
backdrop behind the DJ booth and they
lied they put like various colors and he
looked at him he said oh that looks like
the flag of France and he said just that
make it the flag of France in sequence
and and it became the whole identity of
the first trailer even me he would ask
me what do you want your name to be in
the middle of it we had no idea what my
name was
he gave me various names and then we
went with
which was his grandmother's name which
means forest and I realized after and
that was after I we shot that long
sequence I have a long sequence shot in
film that is where I go crazy
basically I'm at the I'm at my climax of
my my craziness at that moment and I
look at the forest and I just that's the
thing that calmed me down and made me
laugh and got me out of my you know
dementia at that moment and and my name
is forest Salva in Spanish it's like
just all like you put the dust together
he has such incredible to taste they can
such incredible trust in spontaneity and
he works that way I'm curious how your
process as an actor has maybe she
changed shifted as a result of now
working so much more do you have a
typical process for every movie or is it
different for every single thing yeah I
mean I love researching and I love
breaking down the script and writing
down but for this one I had I wasn't
sure I the thing that I was sure about
going on this journey with Gaspard that
I didn't want to be too rigid I didn't
want to have to set ideas that would
gonna make me break at some point
because first of all I couldn't I
couldn't do all the research that I
usually do because I had no idea where I
was going you know all I knew is that I
was this choreographer who was spiked
with a large amount of LSD and I wanted
to find her depths that had an idea but
every day I came to set and I was just
very flexible with everything that I
wanted to do that I had in mind because
Gaspard has a lot to give and has a lot
to to direct you know like he's really
like I follow his guide line very much
so but he listens as well but he knows
what's right what's you know the color
that is right that isn't so I just
wanted to show up with like some sort of
idea this was different like I usually
just really break down everything do a
bunch of research and they write down a
lot of stuff and I couldn't on this on
this one I couldn't learn learn lines I
couldn't I not that it's about that but
he do find a lot of colors through
what's being said about your character
that in the narration and
what other characters say about you and
what you say about yourself and in this
one I had to come up with that and it's
like every day I had to like just be on
my toes and then that just like every
second like every day I had to like
build the characters like maybe I could
go this route make a complete different
character than if I went this route so
every decision was very crucial and
important and I usually also pay
attention to a lot of the other
characters and on this one I couldn't I
had to focus just solely on mine because
it was too much to take on board it was
stressful but so rewarding in the end I
felt really like artistically very free
and very I feel like I could explore
something that was quite unique and
special and I can't wait to have my next
project and see how I can apply what I
learned on this one when in terms of
spontaneity and see how it can
incorporates that to more structure
material yeah it'll be interesting to
see if you end up reverting back to what
you used to do and how much is what what
do you mean oh yeah like you know
interesting to see I can wait to explore
both you know I'm in the film you have
history with dancing and in the film
you're obviously dancing what is it like
when you're coming up with it in the
moment you know how much are you do you
know what I mean like coming up with
these things
you mean the steps yeah um so me and
Nina Nina McNeely who's the
choreographer in the movies who is
insanely talented wanted to present
something to Gaspard before we started
filming and so to show like the
direction that we wanted to go for the
climax moment of my character and and we
ended up working in a way to where she
was filming me and she was sort of
guiding me through the moves while I was
dancing so I was listening to her but I
was also very much in my zone and it
worked for some reason I just listened
to her and I and I and I could pay
attention while I was freaking out and
we said you know just let's just shoot
it that way let's just um you just make
it that way and so we filmed that way
she was behind gas bar with a mic and
sometime I would listen to what she
would say and sometimes I wouldn't but
like tours we did we didn't only seven
takes of that scene because it's pretty
intense and
exhausting but tourists like we had the
exact choreography for the last three
takes and I think for takes in to the
shooting of the scene Gaspard told me
Sofia I really want to shoot you through
this mirror in the bathroom and and I
was like what can take me to the
bathroom and I had this whole moment
where I needed to like to go and wash my
hand and wash some part of my body and I
decided to be talk because I knew I
wanted within that moment to have an arc
and have a moment where I slow down and
having my hands and my tights was like
my comforting moment like I felt tucked
and I've and I thought I need to lose
myself in that and forget that I am have
my hands under my leggings until I want
to get up again and I'm freaking out
because my hands are underneath my skin
and that drags me to the bathroom so
that's the kind of spontaneity that
Gaspard comes up with and I had to sing
so sharply because I had to had only few
minutes to have a reason to what would
take me as an actor to the bathroom
because he wasn't gonna tell me that and
in the last day he told me can do
whatever you want and then that's when I
went in bathroom with my hair and that
was the last take is the one you see in
the movie because we had no time we all
did our own hair and makeup and we had
no time to do any sort of reset it was a
pretty crazy
I really cannot wait to to see I cannot
imagine also all the the different
versions that are on the editing room
floor you know okay before I run out of
time with you so there's a few questions
we've been playing something called get
to know your TIF attendee see very
harmless questions I promise well you
can let me know if you think they are
harmless
what TV show would you love to guest
spot on I'd be a guest like to do one
episode TV show sharp objects do you
have a favorite sci-fi or fantasy film
oh my god
a neverending story did you see that as
like a little kid yes I loved it oh it
was my comfort movie yep I completely
understand what film scared you as a kid
The Exorcist I came across the tape when
I was about 8 years old or something
like that
a little too young a little too young
but you know I was just in shock but I
liked it it's weird are you a fan of the
horror genre are we good could you hear
me before even I was unplugged oh you're
just listening to him you know just what
I'm saying are you she can hear
everything that's fine what do you
collect anything um
do I collect no I think I went through a
phase where I collected stamps when I
was younger just because I thought I
needed to collect something I collect I
don't know hearts do you own any movie
or TV show props
yes thorns that I've been in not you
borrow something from set borrow
I've been gifted like beautiful things
like sometimes like like like a piece of
clothing or like what do we have from
props hmm do I have any proof I'm sure I
do I have so much stuff in my house it's
ridiculous that's too much yes surely a
bigger place that's why it seemed that
much crowded but won't people be
surprised to learn about you I've never
done any stunts before I did Kingsman so
I'd like a lot of people think I come
from that world and I'm and I don't but
I think a lot of people don't know that
that's it and I don't know I'm not as I
don't know what TV show have you watched
all the way through more than once I've
never done that really I have something
with TVs that it gives me sort of
anxiety because it doesn't end so I
wanted like I loved it
I'm done and put it to sleep and as I
can think about it and watch it again it
was TV show I feel like I always have
this anxieties and it sort of I would
binge and and I need to finish it if I
start something I have to finish it like
even movies that I don't like i watch
everything until the end so if that's
why like TV I'm afraid sometimes because
if I start I have to finish whether I
like it or not whether it's good or not
I I have the same problem the same thing
with books no I completely understand
what you're saying my question is so do
you watch any TV or it's very very
selective very very selective so you saw
sharp objects yeah do you watch Game of
Thrones no I can't see okay so everybody
say I tried but it would be way too much
to catch up with that will really stress
me out and Breaking Bad no I haven't but
I won - I really want to do Breaking Bad
yeah that one's really good and it's
also it's it's not that long do you know
what I mean
yeah I recommend that one and also the
wire okay the wire is tremendous what's
the background photo on your phone oh
it's just the thing that comes it's like
the natural thing I should change it but
I didn't bother so it's that boring
thing it's a beach though it just makes
me look forward to my next vacation
have you watched any movie more than 10
times mmm probably I don't know that I
remember pulp fiction maybe were
clearing for a dream which I was
fascinated with when I was a teenager
sure um what else
wings of desire which is movie that I
loved when I was when I was younger
which I came across when I was about 14
yeah and I found out about the remake
long after I was like oh city Evandro
that's wings of desire I would tell
people that is it yes it's very true do
you have a favorite pair of sneakers or
shoes yes I do that I have since I'm
about 16 or 17 I went on tour with it
there's a bunch of people that signed
their name on their names on and just I
still have it and I just I just lost my
pair of Doc Martens which I walked the
world with this I'm not wearing them but
I it's just yeah you lost them and
Austin went on holiday in Italy with a
bunch of friends and I think I left them
behind and they were just gone that's a
pair of shoes I don't know but you know
that sucks
I got a new pair because I just want to
I liked that pair that you go everywhere
with and I have that with my pair of Doc
Martens because they're so easy to wear
and very they're not comfortable to
begin with but they become that sure my
last question for you do you remember
what got you interested in wanting to be
in the entertainment industry I remember
I mean my father's a composer my mom is
an architect and paints and I grew up in
a very artistic family I was always
encouraged to to be creative and so I
always had that and Music's was a very
present art form in my house and I was
moved around I always wanted to
celebrate music I sing and so becoming a
dancer was pretty natural and then I
think after that I I just was fascinated
with Michael Jackson and seeing him on
stage at a very young age I could
understand what he was feeling without
wanting to be a singer at all and that
it's just what drives me is just what's
in my heart to be honest and having that
sort of need and want to express myself
artistically and because I feel very
inspired by a lot of things and so I
just want to be creative and on that
note I'm gonna say tremendously thank
you so much for coming in a huge thank
you again to House of Aurora for being
our awesome sponsor thank you
enjoy TIFF thank you so much you too
you